ce matin que débute à l'assemblée
nationale la commission parlementaire
sur le recyclage et la valorisation du
verre est ce qu'on doit élargir la
fameuse consignes pour les bouteilles on
apprend avec karel ménard directeur
général du front commun québécois pour
une gestion écologique des déchets qui
sera présent d'ailleurs à cette
commission bonjour monsieur ménard
aujourd'hui dames na kwa quelle est
votre position à vous au sujet de la
consigne des bouteilles en fait la
chronique devraient de modéliser donc
effectivement la conseil de l'europe
élargie ou bouteille de la saq mais
aussi à d'autres comptes notamment
l'écouté et oui bon parce que l an de la
commission on va entendre des groupes
des deux côtés de la médaille la
concernant la la consigne et parlez nous
des enjeux à cette commission
aujourd'hui
bon reste un débat qui dure depuis plus
30 ans moi ça fait 25 ans j'ai commencé
en environnement et quand j'ai commencé
on parlait déjà de la consigne est de la
collecte sélective en fait faut savoir
que la quasi-totalité du verre récupéré
dans le bac de récupération donc le bye
bye bye le conte à la maison fini sa vie
malheureusement au dépotoir
donc c'est pas tant qu'il n'y a pas de
marché qui marche ne sont pas possibles
pour recycler le verre ou québec
encore faut-il que le verso de bonne
qualité parce que c'est seul problème le
verre récupéré dans un bac de
récupération se contaminent et n'est
plus apte à être cycliste souvent de
verre ou à d'autres formes de recyclage
donc tout ce qu'on part en face c'est ce
qu'on appelle de la valorisation
donc soit du dieu de la braise et de
l'aménagement paysager
mais pour cela les marchés actuellement
sont saturés donc il faut trouver
d'autres débouchés et pour savoir
bordure de qualité us et peut produire
ça et vous êtes monsieur ménard là que
c'est la quasi-totalité du verre qu'on
met dans notre bac qui s'en va dans un
site d'enfouissement ça c'est
décourageant d'entendre ça ben oui il
est utilisé comme matériel de
recouvrement dont il n'est pas
techniquement enfouis ou éliminer donc
de trouver une façon plus nobles entre
guillemets de dire qu'on quand la meinau
dépotoir mais il finit malgré tout quand
même sa vie au dépotoir on n'a pas les
chiffres exacts parce qu'il est juif qui
n'en sont très vieux c'est un autre
problème 7-0 niveau de l'aide est donné
on n'a pas ce genre de données là mais
on sait qu'il ya très peu de vin qui
ruscus homme de 20 ans belge pourrait
presque avancé que 0% du verre
perry par la collecte sélective
municipale est transformé en d'autres
contenants de verre donc le par contre
et du verre recyclé ou québec sous forme
de dons qu'on aurait fondu mais sur du
verre qui issus de la consigne de me
limiter de bière ou des bouteilles qui
sont consignés et dans d'autres
provinces l'ontario où les provinces
maritimes par exemple mais pourquoi
c'est si compliqué de trouver une
solution pour les bouteilles de vin
alors que la plupart des bouteilles de
bière sont consignés la tendance
mondiale aussi c'était la consigne
pourquoi c'est si compliqué d'y arriver
la consigne faut comprendre que c'est
simplement un mode de récupération
les bouteilles de bière comme
l'embouteillage se fait au québec la
plupart sont réutilisés donc la vistule
et 10 est remplie de bières à nouveau au
niveau du vin le vin bien souvent
provient presque tout le temps vient de
l'étranger donc ce ne serait pas du une
consigne à des fins de réutilisation
mais bien de recyclage donc on visait le
matériau le vert pour être recyclés
comme par exemple lors comme une
bouteille dans une machine une t de
boissons gazeuses dans une qobuz de
compte comme on dit communément la
bouteille dit pas re remplir à nouveau
on récupère le plastique qui qui
risquent les mains d'avoir une meilleure
qualité de vin c'est ça c'est ça parce
que la clé c'est récupéré de façon
séparée les matériaux on a le même
problème au niveau du papier au niveau
de la fibre ça veut dire lorsqu on
récupère mélangé avec d'autres matières
du métal du plastique du verre le papier
a de la difficulté à trouver des
preneurs
ici au québec dont volant on doit
l'envoyer là où les pays sont peut-être
moins regardants ou peut-être le la main
d'oeuvre est moins chère au niveau du
verre ont malheureusement on ne peut pas
exporter le vert parce que c'est rouleau
et le vert il ya personne qui en veut en
fait et la problématique est mondiale
donc le vert faut vraiment trouver des
solutions locales ici donc faut
diversifier les marchés
donc il doit juste la réforme et
plusieurs applications qu'on peut faire
ouvert encore comme j'ai dit encore faut
il avoir du vin de bonne qualité qui
satisfasse les conditionneurs et le
recycleur wi fi de la volonté aussi
parce que la société des alcools du
québec la saq s'est opposé à
l'instauration d'une consigne
effectivement mais la saq fait partie du
gouvernement aussi donc on
gouvernement qui est très proche des
préoccupations des citoyens et je crois
que c'est près de 95 % des citoyens qui
sont en faveur d'une consigne sur les
bouteilles de vins et de spiritueux dans
ce qui donc nous tous les espoirs sont
sont là et en fait j'aurais presque
tendance à dire il faut trouver une
solution parce que là ça fait plus de
trente ans qu'on en parle
le statu quo n'est plus acceptable donc
il faut véritablement cette année en
fait je dirais même à l'automne con con
qu'on règle le départ une bonne fois
pour toutes alors que ramène un
directeur général du front commun
québécois pour une gestion écologique
des déchets on va si bien sûr le
déroulement de cette commission sur le
recyclage du verre merci beaucoup merci
à vous bonnes gens dormant